いきなりですが引っ越します
よだれが出たよターンなり早いでしょユーチューバーでこんなに早く引っ越せして他に
いるかやいない俺が最速ながらデイズ理由がありますひとつ目となりにファミリー書き
ましたこれはからよねどうしようもなかった僕は今までですねこの家も前のいえばです
ね今まで隣に人がになってかつ角部屋だったので打っず声を出しても誰にも迷惑は
かからなかったんですよ
けどなんとなんとですねにもとなる投げるに家族きててなかなか動画自体が取れない
状況にあります
別2に生活したら全然いけると思うんですけど僕の場合声出したりなんか博打
爆竹が投げないぞ大きい声出したり簿の夫と語ったりしちゃうね僕はちょっと人に迷惑
をかけてもいいと僕は取り食べないなんて思ってるねーー福岡市はショックは氏は紹介
シワシワだまあこれがまず引っ越すするための理由一つ隣で家族が来たので迷惑分家
たくないんで日もう一つとても
当院ですいろんな人が僕ん家に勝手に来たりするんでそれを防止するため長や多くに来
たんですけどや僕に来たの良かった人も来なくなったしてこなくなった皆さん
ありがとう
だったんだけれども実はここから僕の学校に行くの30分とか来るんですね大作戦と約
1時間かかるってそれを1か月使うと30時間のタイムロスになるバイクで移動する
からバイクの続き
にもできないフルに30時間時間のロスが起きる
をてつだってくれる人来ましたレイジですね何か言いたいかと言うと隣に数が来たのだ
ねうん
家族きた子と同等位すべてにおいて遠い時間はなぁお金に変えない過疎って後のやレア
コンビニがない
そうあの近くにお店がないんで最寄りのコンビニ1キロ以上先にあるんで
ん
生活するとかよっと苦痛の引っ越す前に分かればいつも良かったんですけどもしっこぜ
してからじゃないとわからないこともあったんで
今回は叱らないかなと思っております逆にかける
約2カ月間おしゃれやさー
ぜ引越します
[音楽]
んだった
seesaa
バスケとろこえー
ないよ
あ
すーっ
うーん爆竹入ってだああ
tan
しぞっ
woopie ても静かでいいところでしたん
たぞ
ブーバーし今度こそちゃんと4落ち着いて生活できるように行きたいと思います姉所
ジャンプデーパターン言っちゃあしっに行ってきましたぁーぬーっニャー
バイトとかさここで作ったパターンレア本とだろうん
カーズとかもあのねぇ憎悪も言わないし実はまだ何もないんです
引っ越しもねぇまぁなくじゃないんですよ猫施行者とか使って内で保管にはそんな
かかってないんですけど今インターネットが使えないのとフレイザードがない
電子レンジもない栄光もないちょっとまだね本当にね何
もないんで分譲に整えていき舌ここでちょっと生活しないことを言いますついに始まっ
たぜ
2015年度初め社長だ
[音楽]
しています